hey youtubers is Charlie so huge news
about Supergirl season 2 so we have a
whole bunch of Superman stuff to talk
about but they just teased a new
character they're bringing on that
connects them to the Justice League
Batman V Superman universe so I'll
explain what's going on but it's like
flash newspaper level big so most of you
have probably seen at least one version
of metallo on screen he's been in the TV
shows he's been in the animated series
so far the movies have not done a
version of him but when you're talking
about the actual metallo character he
just like one of the stable of
Superman's most classic villains because
John Corben himself is such an
interesting character and because he's
human who's turned into this machine
he's a lot more compelling so it's just
a lot of fun for writers to use him and
from the pictures from the set we cuz
he's Superman it's gonna be wearing a
special variation on his costume that
will help him handle metallo just
because the big twist of metallus powers
are is that he has multiple different
types of Kryptonite in his chest so it's
like during the flash season 2 when
Barry was trying to fight against the
turtle so you know someone who absorbed
his kinetic energy so there's like a
whole lot of stuff going on here one
this is actually taking place in what
looks like metropolis that's where a
super girl season 2 will go to
Metropolis is doing a whole bunch of
Superman stuff which is actually
probably the biggest news like we know
that Superman's going to be in the first
two episodes so that's probably what all
this is take it from me like a big
classic Superman adventure with a really
classic Superman villain but going
forward this kind of lets you know like
if they can go to Metropolis they can do
Superman they can do some of Superman's
biggest villains what else can the TV
shows do and the answer is there's
probably most things like this just
makes it seem like the door is wide open
for them to tell whatever awesome story
they want without having to worry about
whether or not a character is okay to do
which i think is one of the problems
with Supergirl season 1 is that there
was like so much stuff that they
couldn't do Maxwell Lord is an
interesting character but the way they
were using him in season 1 was basically
as they're stand-in for Lex Luthor like
we can't do Lex Luthor so we're gonna do
a slightly different version of him
remember all the cool stuff that Maxwell
Lord could do in the comics how he's one
of the most powerful telepaths on the
earth we're not going to do any of that
stuff so now in season 2 that we're on
the CW we're doing a big four night
crossover we have
Superman that just lets you know that
they are not shackled by any of those
storytelling restrictions anymore so I'm
just so happy about the potential that
they have now they haven't officially
confirmed all the villains they're
bringing on but actually on Thursday
next week the CW is having its big tcas
panel where it explains to television
critics some of the stuff that it's
doing with the new shows so what I'm
expecting is is they'll be talking about
what's going on in the flash season
three with flash points they'll probably
explain that four night crossover a
little bit better how that's gonna work
and they'll explain what is going to be
different about Supergirl season to this
season but you've kind of already seen
it with all these Superman pictures like
you have Stephen Amell here
Green Arrow standing next to Superman
looking like they just double parked the
invisible jet because they're late to a
baseball game and on top of that for
those who that are big fans of the
Merlin series Katie McGrath played
Morgan lepay she's going to be coming on
season two as Leena Luthor
so the Luthor family does exist in the
Supergirl Universe I mean we kind of
knew it did because previously movie
stuff was off-limits it was just a big
question mark the description of her
character will blow your mind a little
bit too it says she comes to National
City fresh on the heels of her brother
Lex Luthor's incarceration so you're
like wait a minute wait are they talking
about Batman V Superman Lex Luthor in
prison oh my god everything is connected
don't jump the gun on that but they are
winking at that big time it just says
that the lena luthor character isn't
gonna be like a total to Cara
she's gonna try and rebrand Luthor Corp
and try and do good things but as we
know about the history between the
Luthor family Luthor Corp and Superman
things will probably not go according to
plan so at this point there's so much
stuff happening I wouldn't be surprised
if we saw more Wayne Corp Easter eggs
and everybody always points to that
flash newspaper like Queen industries
Wayne Corp merger to be honest about
that when they first did that in the
flash pilot it was a joke they were not
setting anything up they're like we'll
never be able to do this ha ha you know
just kind of laughing at each other but
it just goes to show that there's no way
to predict about how things changing
behind the scenes can affect what they
can do on the TV shows so if we can do
Luthor's we can do Superman we can
probably do Batman at some time in the
near future so I'm expecting a whole
bunch of news to drop next week
but I know a lot of you are asking
what's going on with Superman later this
season is he gonna come back more often
is he going to cross over during the
four night crossover like will we
actually see green arrow on screen with
Superman I'm not expecting it but it's
always possible what I think is gonna
happen with Superman this season on
Supergirl is they said that he's an
important part of Cara story he's going
to be butting heads with her Allah or
Cara it's gonna be betting heads with
him
but this is Cara's sophomore year as
Supergirl so she's still kind of dirt
being she's trying to figure things out
what it means to be a superhero what's
the best way to go about saving people
Superman has his own thesis of what a
superhero should be how they should act
cars will be slightly different from
that so a lot of their conflict will be
around that but he's still gonna be
something of a mentor to her so because
he's not a series regular what I'm
expecting is is that we'll see him in
the first couple of episodes he might
come back around the mid-season finale
and then a couple times in the back half
of the season so appearing in slightly
less than half of the episode so
anywhere between like six and eight
episodes this season of twenty total
there are 20 episodes total but the real
big question is crossover I don't know
about the four-night crossover because
they said that Supergirl is gonna lead
the charge so they might say something
different to the press conference next
week but it sounds like she's gonna be
the only one from the Supergirl TV show
to jump from show to show maybe Martian
Manhunter - so when a lot of you are
confused about the person and the
capsule that looks like it might be the
TV shows version of Superboy like the
Mon L version of the character so he
sounds like he's going to be more of a
series regular like a person you see
every single week so in terms of the
Kryptonian dynamic on the show just
expect there to be more awesome
Kryptonian characters namely among them
Superman and I will say you know like if
Superman doesn't cross over a lot with
the other TV shows this year that will
probably change in future years so in
related news kind of the same thing is
happening with legends of tomorrow
like they just tweeted this image
they're going full-blown Justice Society
they're doing Legion of Doom that's
actually even more comic book than doing
Justice Society just a society huge
comic book team but Legion of Doom is a
super deep cut because they came from
the Superfriends the Legion of Doom
didn't originate in the comics it
actually started on that old cartoon
show in the Darth Vader helmet then made
its way into the comics so I was just so
happy when I
so all of these things start dropping
around Comic Con like we got Superman
back we got crazy Darth Vader team-up
led by the reverse-flash it's like if
somebody were just going down your
checklist of all the things you would
want from a TV show when you're a little
kid like okay I want the reverse-flash
I want the Legion of Doom I want a big
villain team-up I don't want to see a
big superhero team-up I want to see
Superman kicking a bunch of ass and I
want to see all these superheroes
crossover during the same week so in
celebration I'll say congratulations to
Haroon for ring you win this week's
giveaway it's a $20 Amazon gift card be
sure to private message me on the back
end of my channel so I can get your
contact details but I will say you know
new round of the giveaway starts now
there's still a bunch of Suicide Squad
videos that I want to make like an
easter egg video and a bunch of other
stuff about the sequels that I think
they're gonna be doing there's new Game
of Thrones stuff that's happening next
week and there's some really cool Luke
Cage stuff that I want to post so those
will be the next videos that I'm working
on I'm also trying to play through
Batman telltale so they'll probably be
some Batman telltale gameplay videos in
the next couple days to where you guys
wait for my next video to post you can
click here for my non-spoilery Suicide
Squad review be sure to go see the movie
this weekend and you can click here to
learn more about what the reverse-flash
has been saying about flash season 3
flashpoint stuff thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five
big Justice League high five I'll see
you guys tonight